hello my name is Mike Denny and welcome
to this week in Android development on
Monday january twenty seven twenty
fourteen last week nozzle and his
special guests Laura Klein discussed the
differences between qualitative and
quantitative measurement on you XD Todd
continued his onslaught of learning neto
marin lectured us on design in
portuguese and tony chan spoke to us in
both Mandarin and in Cantonese on what's
new in Android 4.4 KitKat this week Todd
continues to take us to school on
achievement enums Joe Fernandez makes
his debut on dev bytes showing us how to
record apt videos directly on our
Android devices using only a USB cable
and ADB and finally there are two
special episodes being released later
this week the first is a play bite from
Todd and the second is a dev bite from
Paul karf make sure to subscribe to our
YouTube channel so you don't miss them
that's all for this week in Android
development I'm Mike Denny until next
time just hold on we're going home